I'm Giles I hail from King's College
London's Department of digital
humanities there is such a thing I do
the tech on the add data ourselves
project along with three other through
the non-technical colleagues two of whom
are into cultural studies and like their
alliteration hence the data democracy
deficit and the projects about the the
trail of mobile phone data that most of
us do rather tend to leave behind so
little aside it's kind of interesting to
see how data science is viewed from
outside there a couple of pop culture
references there's a book that I haven't
read but the net someone on the natural
language processing gate project team in
Sheffield has the the data scientist is
the is the hero going around disrupting
things as people around old Street I
want to do using social media to predict
the stock market in it's a thriller but
actually we mostly get our data back to
us in the form of targeted ads and it
doesn't always work particularly well
I'm trying to have a particularly grim
example from privatized malga rhythms
column where they highlight particularly
I agree more amusing examples of ad
placement and suffice it to say if
you're talking about a Holocaust
Memorial not being built you don't want
an advert about walk-in showers that's
rather darker then I'd that we perhaps
see what it would have wanted for for
Sunday morning so can we do better I'd
suggest that we can but how aware are
mobile device users of this if we can we
gather their data and confront them with
it and to what else could do to what
other uses could it be put to can we
build what my my cultural studies
colleagues insist on calling a mobile
data Commons
so can we capture the trail of data that
comes from your phone with a nap what's
the question posting no it's a
stunningly bad idea one it involves that
your your your phone would be your at
least your Android phone will be rooted
so your Android phone is after all
juiced up cut down linux machine and you
actually don't have admin permission
over it take my watch off so now I'm
doing which is interesting in itself
because you have apps that have a little
internal sequel light databases all
about you and if you plug your your
phone into your into your laptop and
mount it's a mass storage device you
don't get to see it because you don't
have root permission and even if even if
I hypothetically you know did write an
app that required root permissions what
best case scenario if I if we ever get
to the Play Store no one would download
it because it's another barrier to entry
which i think is better than Pete
everyone going yeah I'll root my phone
so I can use this app and I've got to go
well obviously I don't know the
individual specifications of all your
phones I can't do their a sort of so
many of you hopefully so if you do root
your phone do make sure you don't use
the method you use a method that turns
out to be malware a no I mean I don't
want to be responsible for that so when
if you I must rest we shall we shall
slide share these slides directly
afterwards if you wanted to horror story
about android permissions wonderful
taught by a security researcher Calder
Georgia Weidman another little aside
which I'm probably gonna be many I'm
quite fond of since I well I started off
this project so the person just go
install app quick big set permissions
yes after after doing a sort of you know
about year and a half I've now turned
into someone who goes except permissions
click I'll hang on I probably should
have read those so we the permissions
model doesn't work so if we can't root
the phone what can we do well we did
eventually at least eventually
perpetrator than that which we call
mobile minor and you can work out by and
large when other apps access the net
you can track things that other ex that
are the raps typically track like seller
DS wireless networks and there's a
particularly cheap trick that I've used
to log when apps send your notifications
so we gave 20 young developers from an
organization called realize say that
organizes hack days android phones and
to get them with that they did actually
join in on the app development we've
created this app what's it doing now
we've seen there's a big stop button you
can stop it from gathering data it's up
to you i'm on the wireless network
access kings at king's college london
there's a cell tower ID and clones mean
up to something that the IP addresses of
a rubbish they're just between the phone
and the and the router but what's
actually quite telling is the port so
how often is chrome doing things on the
unsecured ports I might gloss over I
might come back to the issues of the
young coders later so a little bit more
depth about the getting of the the data
so Android there's an API you can just
go I mean the Pythons coming I had to
suffer the Java cars can see why you
where you should get off lightly either
you can on a per-app basis just go how
much data has this app used and you can
prod that API call repeatedly and if the
numbers increasing then you know you've
got some sort of network usage event
also you couldn't you're quite at
liberty to fair it around in the
underlying Linux system so / proc /
whatever the process ID of the of the
Android app / net / tcp it's a pretty
standard format it doesn't always work
depending on the sort of the group the
Linux groups at your app and the other
apps are put in but by and large
browsers worked skype another VoIP
services works a lot of music worked
some games more about which later so we
can get we can get network data gsm
cells didn't fancy collecting full GPS
share this data it's just too invasive
it consumes power I don't want to sign
up the teasel you know for the Google's
their location API T's and C's one is
anyway because you can't really separate
location based on wireless networks from
location based on GSM networks and often
especially around here if we're in a GP
a-- in a sort of GPS shadow the wireless
network information is more invasive
anyway so I mean it is a little heat map
that the app produced it's got that i
live in highgate but it's got me the
wrong side of the archway Road I can
breathe some sort of slightly about
where people live and what they do but
it's just it's not too it's just it's
not too invasive it's not too creepy and
you can turn you can turn Geo some
locations into latitude longitude some
lovely people open cell ID and they have
some slightly sparse but it is growing
they have a crowd-sourced database of
locations so we've got an app that's
churning out all this data and I want to
collect it I want to be able to display
it play with it mess with it in we're do
machine learning on in a hopefully a
Python it way how am I going to do that
well step forward today c-can and
nobody's heard of it well not in data
science circles is interesting to the
point where how was it a sort of a
vaguely tech do in a pub and it was a
bit noisy and I started talking about
c-can and somebody approached me her
eyes this up wow I'm not the only pearl
dev in London not sorry you are I wasn't
talking about Sipan can so it's um it's
um
how do what we call it it's a CMS a
content management system for data it's
produced by the open knowledge
foundation it's written in Python it can
integrate with Drupal app and there's
data business analytics wonderful sits
it calls itself sometimes it's really
refers to itself as the Drupal of data
it's not that bad actually fairly light
from dependences it wants postgres and
apache solr for search it's based on
pylons more about that later now not
loaded by default but there's a plugin
or datastore plugin and it provides an
82 might you know it's mostly about
government institutions dolloping large
they sets all at once but you can have
an API for quickly and easily getting
allowing I think some sort of API for
uploading data piecemeal runs in a
virtual end and it works I mean I'm my
project would not have worked without it
it saved me rather a lot of time and
rather lot of code so it basically
worked as an out-of-the-box solution
saying that now I haven't contributed a
line of code to see can and I'm must say
it you know it worked well for us but
you'll be a bit remiss of me if I didn't
mention if I didn't sort of criticize
some other things I think it's a little
bit lacking though I mean I must rest up
not lifted a finger to solve any of
these problems so there it is I mean it
gives you maps there's a nice little map
of all the various gsm cells or at least
the first hundred of them that people
have visited there's my trip to Wales
I'm in this thing too and more on that
later and just just show you how easy it
is to write a plug-in so we the phone
app is going to have to clean somehow
register and you it's that it's it's
been installed and ask for a UID we're
going to have a class that extends
sea-cans plug-in object we're going to
say i implement the authorization
functions or rather i implement the
author the the actions api two functions
that just returned dictionaries
and let's say minor register is that you
are easily the endpoint to the end of
the URL and it's going to point to a
function called minor datastore register
easy just give an example slap a
decorator on top of this function it's
going to get past the data that's that
comes from the post request we've got a
list in comprehension as i like to call
it that poop unit produces a list of
things that aren't in the in the post
data that should be if there are things
missing it's easy enough to raise a
sensible error message so we're after
the the Android ID and loving another
version of the app create a new user ID
assuming they don't already make sure
they don't already exist and we've just
got local referring to a sea-can
instance data store upsert the resource
we're going to put it into the the user
table and we just give it a list of
dictionaries the user ID the android ID
done that's you know that's just for the
app registering a you know it's itself
as a new user you can imagine the code
for actually spitting out the spitting
up the data is being split a little more
validation easy let's have a look at the
real thing can we ah yeah let's look at
a real one oh can I move my window have
a look at the real thing
so there's one running locally datasets
move our minor app data let's look at
the let's look at the user locations
again we need I I don't know why the
views haven't been created data Explorer
call it default view and
okay there's a and here we see some of
the limitations I mean it's not it's you
know you can't expect miracles it's not
the result of an ER Dave banging your
head against the bouquet library so
right that I don't zoom in well never if
we look at the look at the grid view
there's okay it's you know colored the
points in blue is there somewhere having
a categorical variable for different
colors for different users no can't be
said witchcraft apparently we can filter
and sort things if we had a you know if
you had a date feel that was meaningful
to sort if I if I want to filter on this
UID can I drag it I can't eat no I can't
even it's there are limitations to the
you know to the UX fair enough also look
at the list of tables again in fact
let's discover to the present let's go
back to the slides
ah come on
if you have things like just a list of
user a used app be at such and such I
mean that in itself is not particularly
useful we was like certain that's what
if we wanted a sort of daily aggregate
per user per app we could turn into a
diary because we had my learned
colleagues were having the the you know
the kids great tumblr dies we could
compare that well you think well can I
just specify got postgres can i specify
a query within the within the user
interface and just create that derive
table apparently not so it but luckily
seekin does import me a run things I'll
you can't you can just have a cron job
and you can create derived tables like
that on a nightly basis and it does that
using celery so seek and support celery
will have a little Lord about that it's
a distributed task queue now that I
don't if anyone for the last talk is
there but there was a guy who was doing
social media analytics with the making
it doing often start leo from scratch we
twisted it's a distributed task queue so
you can create pipelines part of
building up being a bigger tasks from
smaller ones in a sort of a way much
like Apache storm in fact there are
people who've abandoned Apache storm for
the celery so you can composing have
tasks going on your split across
multiple machines there's our lovely
online tool called flower for monitoring
tasks instead of seeing which node is
doing how much of the work so great we
can we can do proper data science and
it's all within this we can embed it
within this this Python it where web app
actually it can't they've gone and
chosen as the the method by which the
the celery tasks talk to each other
they've gone and used the database as
the broker which celery themselves say
is particularly flaky and a thing not to
do now you could argue that look they
didn't intend to be a data science
platform their app data storage for me
that's a little bit of a universe or a
missed opportunity in a a failure
ambition you can actually get
getsy can to use a proper broker within
within within celery it's not
particularly well documented however so
okay but what I what the other little
niggle that I really can't forgive we've
got five years yet gratuitous Bowie
reference but with a purpose we've got
five years of supported Python 2.7 see
can still says it'll support 2.6 now
they've got a roadmap and Python 3 isn't
on it the most urgent thing they're
doing right now is per data set issue
tracker for users to report back and
track issues with data sets now again
it's built on the web framework pylons
which is now mutated into pyramid
pyramid supports Python 3 and there was
a migration guide from pylons to pyramid
written in 2011 so I mean must stress
secant it worked for us it allowed us to
collect the data it allowed us to chill
soon sea turtle you know to mess with
the data and do amusing things with it
but how much of a deal breaker is the
lack of Python 3 and if you've built
yourself a huge teetering stack of
secret extensions how badly are going to
break when Python 3 does arrive so bear
in mind but again and spend I mean
python3 onion oh I'd so love to not have
Unicode hassles so it's not perfect but
list of the doom and gloom that's
actually do something with the data so
we got cell towers can we say anything
about the users from the list of self
now seeing are the trails of cell towers
they create well it's pretty noisy data
I mean people might not have been using
the app they might have just not had
signal and the cell tower you connect to
has as much to do with economics and
network traffic as it does in a being a
proxy for for position not all the cell
towers are known to open psyd anyway and
I accidentally left this thing running
in my pocket when I was going to the
connected communities festival at
Cardiff and you can see there's a
there are massive gaps in the in the
trail so if we want to look at some sort
of clustering algorithm to sort of look
at user behavior you got to take into
account note I mean if you have a short
discussion of the clustering algunos
you're not going to use DB scan DB scan
asks you to sort of estimate that then
the sort of minimum density between
points in a cluster and because it's so
variable it works on so many length
scales it's not going to cut it so it's
going to be k-means now this is meant to
be intermediate is that anyone utter Lee
unfamiliar with k-means good so but we
shall need to explain the nice little
animation but a little sort of checklist
as to whether we should be using it
convex clusters lumps should a fairly
compact so if you got tweaked sort of
stretched out noodley extended things
you'll tend to get clusters that cut
them in half same number of dimensions
and actually measuring the distance
between points and clusters as I've been
in terms of an occlusion distance should
be should make sense and sky kit learn
enforces this you cannot pass in a
function that's going to measure the
distance between points like you can
with DB scan and people do abuse k-means
I've seen tweets as vectors with the
sort of binary features got word not got
word and they can as was mentioned in
the last talk their computing Jaccard
distance it's it's odd so as a look mind
you the same individual who ditched
Apache storm for celery has abused
k-means and in a good way but that's
because they're they're really really
clever possibly cleverer than I so how
about let's have a go at K means we are
just try latitude and longitude as
feature vectors now I don't have any one
went to the the geodata tutorial but
we've we've kind of treating spherical
polar coordinates as Cartesian so maybe
a little bit of a caution so long as
none of the kids using the app join the
British Antarctic Survey and go
massively far south will probably get
away with it so just as you tend to do
with k-means increase K until the
distance they know the mean distance
before on from each point to its
assigned cluster centroid stops
decreasing appreciably let's have a
let's have a first go have a look well
one of the one of the first conditions
for using k-means has already been a
little bit violated because well if you
have these trails of points now could
say that looks like a journey when it's
been split into three and we've got
these blobby clusters that make a bit
more sense can we do any better how
about latitude longitude and their rates
of change not bad again the the two with
the three extended clusters have been
turned into two so you could conceivably
think of a journey that's there and
maybe back again so k's reduced the
trails of points of coalesced not much
consultation to work the thinner to
think that one up quit while you're
ahead no no we never learn could we have
the spatial temporal clustering so we
can sort of track users habits that way
it's day of a week a good a good feature
well if it was you or your to build a
finds thing that sir there's one cluster
that's active over all the weekdays as
opposed to weekends but it's not where
this individual goes to school so it's
kind of failed there we've got points
leaking from one spatially relevant
cluster to another just because they
have they have days in common add the
how does that help again not really
there's nothing that looks like a nine
to five and there is one well how about
what if we were to take the the 24 and
the seven temporal features and have a
matrix in having to do a sort of cross
products with the for spatial features
and get a massively massive matrix which
we flatten into a stupid
large vet no stop it stop abusing
k-means deuce links simple instead we've
got a time series of gsm cells which we
can turn into a time series of cluster
visits and they just look at the numbers
and the other the times of the point of
the visits for each cluster count them
how many distinct days as each cluster
visited on what's the range of days of
occupation does it tend to be
proportionally obviously normalized it
over five out of seven is it occupied
more on weekdays or weekends and slight
bit of moderate cleverness with numpy
can we look at the range of the times of
day when the clusters occupied so if it
tends to be occupied at night all days
of the week that's where you live have
we found a cluster that's occupied from
nine to five of a weekday that's work or
school we chucked the latitude and
longitudes at openstreetmap and we
worked at largely when we know where
most of the young reword state
volunteers we're going to school yep to
remember apps relapse don't just have
your location data your meta data they
also have that your your content as well
they stop can we get any greater
insights what if you're a student and
you've visited multiple cities two
occasions each separated by a couple of
weeks each what are you doing well
you're going to university open days and
you're attending interviews and the
purpose of this was just to confront the
young reword states with the data Tina
did you get to get a response and to
sort of provoke discussion with my
cultural studies colleagues so he said
he no hello you've applied to these
universities here's where you go to
school do you have a slightly different
attitude to Foursquare now maybe so we
want to give the data back you want them
to have this data and play with it we
just you know not just static CSV files
we want them to have what we have so not
just the copy of the secant instance
because as you've seen the UI is a bit
limited we
want them to plot their data by a knife
or notebook wanna throw in SK learn the
same as we had an umpire all the things
we had and what we want we want a
virtual machine that I can modify
document distribute and if I make
changes I don't have to sort of start
from scratch rebuilding it so step
forward dhaka it's been very it's been
very popular in pi day to meet at
lightning talks for those of a sort of
non linux ii disposition in fact making
reference to yesterday's afternoon
keynote if you sort of imagine that your
your machine has a case of multiple
personality disorder and sort of it
believes that certain chunks of it or
somebody else so back in this so it's
about using the linux container kernel
modules so we have a docker file that
specifies how an images built images
instantiate containers now it's bisque
it's kind of strictly linux now there is
boot to dock of a mac and windows it's
just a it's just a virtual box with a
lick of paint and sort of specially
purposed for running doctor images we
found that you know nobody managed to
particularly get on with booted docker
and everyone could use virtualbox we
just shoved our verse shoved a docker
image inside a grub containers rather
inside a virtual box now i don't know if
anyone had trouble with stubborn pip
installs in the in the tutorials I
certainly did I know I know others did
so if you imagine on the on college
Wi-Fi giving out all those all those
services Apache and solar and all the
libraries and I sort of building various
bits of sky kit learn did it work yes
everyone had their data in a night
python notebook and they could query it
and play with it and talk to each other
about it so that solutions have been a
proper hat day and in the widest sense
we had kids like should showing each
other the sort of distribution of when
Spotify phoned home for them and they go
look that's me on the treadmill
ill that's the walk to school that I
must admit is insomnia an exam stress
list I think what if I'm telling you
this what if I must know this and it's
not so sort of think about the date or a
bit more dakka dakka is great for you
criticisms number of times you look on
the the sort of the docker hub and you
see no docker file well why don't I just
sudo w get not dodgy honest guv install
Dutch and pipe it through pipe it
through my shell yeah I'll do that on my
box or on my server show us the docker
file which in our instance we have there
are proper sysadmin types who have
criticized it within in this case in a
particular so critically absurd user bit
but to actually fairly measured way in
the end going that's not proper sysadmin
get off my lawn and we might have a
point it doesn't work with oak and
OpenStack particularly well but for our
purposes having a virtual machine that I
can document change easily and give away
wonderful now I've had to dig up or I'll
see cancer I must say the the canonical
way of starting multiple services at the
end of your your docker container at the
end of your dacha file is you supervisor
d it's in Python it's not in Python 3
yet more data it's actually do stuff
with data again so we've got we've got
that we logging the times when apps
phone own will send notifications does
actually tell us anything about the app
or the user or both look at social
networks now we know who these
individuals are so we know there that we
know who they're what they're doing that
their Twitter accounts are we look at
your degree of your Twitter network
versus the number of notifications well
if you've got a lot of friends and if
you haven't used Twitter in five minutes
it'll start wondering where you are and
going so and so it's got a tweaked view
it's pretty binary either you're quite
into Twitter or you're very into Twitter
and the more the more notifications you
get it's a moderately decent binary
predictor of the weld it with you know
whether you're into Twitter or not and
you're you're
count followers of course you only get a
notification based on followers if they
do something like favorite or retweet
something so it's it's a bit noisier
games are interesting so is network
activity still approxi for abuse you can
actually look it's also a sort of a time
a series of someone's interest in the
game peeking and then sort of dying away
it's also interesting to look at the
distribution of Ali behavior so it's I
guess vaguely normal keen in the
mornings reaches us at a peak and
evening some people are some diehards at
the end and it tells off play it bees a
bit keen on this game but we really
worried about them with this thing
there's not a hour in the day when the
thing isn't phoning home what could it
be me we know it the kid can't be
playing it that frequently that have
sort of died one of these tragic
multiple masa you know MMO world of
warcraft deaths like you know that sort
of that happen so what was it it was a
stupid little line following game every
time he crashed it served you an ad i
want in a numb with but in fact absolute
seriousness it I want to know why it
thinks I need a Ukrainian mail-order
bride I'm not actually joking would get
onto this it wants all the permissions
in the world and this sort of provoke
just thinking what what is it doing how
long have I had une getting getting to
the end right so started getting a pro
app reversal tools there's a thing
called APU can get the package the the
Android package you can decompile it
there's a file in there called
androidmanifest.xml and you can see oh
it's it's got all these different
services people J push you menge there's
there's also a ten-cent to a very big in
in China you can start decompiling
looking at the source code and then you
know there's the smoking gun for some
reason it's a bleed some comparing my
a latitude to 29 degrees for some reason
making a decision as to whether to serve
an app on the Apple and add or not but
what that was easy I thought well anyone
can do that can't lay so again another
another use case for docker just to show
if you're sort of holding some sort of
hack day if you want to distribute to
massive chunks of tools and code ducker
is probably the way to go so we got
whole load of android app reversal tools
a lot of them wanted building some sauce
in it and sauce not the sort of thing
you want to sort of a have people doing
on the day on the on college Wi-Fi and
because the nice individual that did the
urban to VNC desktop has given us his
dacha file we can mess with it and
change it and we held a master class on
app reversal held by my learned
colleague Darren martin now after zyphus
research and we jokingly said to each
other we're doing science I mean can you
expect this to work we're giving sort of
civilians off the street who have never
seen the shell so much as seen the shell
before are they going to do a traversal
is it going to work and there was it was
one I'm going to embarrass him but the
story ends well was one lad first seal
hanging outside the door waiting for it
to start he'd brought I said that bring
a laptop to a hack day to a hand roid
hacking party he had brought an ipad
with a keyboard attached i thought oh
this isn't going to end well he was back
after lunch with his laptop and by the
end of it he was running around telling
people how to use wireshark everybody me
particularly in fact that they were the
non-technical people really stepped up
to the plate they were said I think
protecting aperture protected by their
naivety of the sort of the enormity of
the task which is how they were I think
able to carry it through but they were
asking massively pertinent questions
they were interested what's brute really
mean what's a dalvik virtual machine
then questions questions questions so
the Python community prides itself in
its openness I think we should really
really hold ourselves to those sorts of
standards
who knew that was a server whole crowd
of latent Android reversal experts
wandering around well they're probably
latent data scientists and Python isters
wandering around if only we considered
welcome them so yep there's Wireshark
there's the line phoning home I might
talk about some other but I think I ask
you a question we find that you ask me
questions download our app go on don't
be frightened give me your life follow
us on Twitter that's where the slides
will be there's our blog don't bother
about the slide she'll link i think the
key thing is the the key thing is the
the Twitter account I think that's
coming up to just about half an hour I
might add about where we're going next
if anyone's interested but the [ __ ] the
question of our sku is we've got this
data we want to sort of turn it into
this this social comments we've got some
ideas about that as to how we might
safely and legitimately and ethically
share the data what would you do with it
it's my question to you first are
failing that any questions silence
yep so one of the one of the things that
people very interested in doing is
seeing how different groups of people
are responding to community and social
events there's been other talks and
other other things discussing behavior
jury to like the riot tau to reverse
protests on so forth predictors of
social unrest and that kind of thing and
an anonymized data set just showing mass
movements is of interest to organizers
of events you know if you're you're
running a you know weekend event and
you're expecting a whole lot of people
turn up quite useful to know the Vance
whether they're actually arriving so you
know there's all sorts of potential uses
if if you can if you could safely share
the data not trace it back i will i'll
get back to on that that's interesting i
mean there are loads of papers and
visualizations where people have gone
cap in hand to a mobile phone provider
and come back with a bag of data but
they've signed the NDA they're very
limited as to what they can do with it
and here it is being crowd-sourced so
two possible ways we can go and there's
definitely one way I know I'm going
where's my browser come on oh it's where
I left it right let's see
no not them they were both coming later
but I've gone and lost the tab i will
come back to these people there is a bit
of software from MIT called open PDS and
the next stage is to have that you put
the conceit is you get your own little
personal data store which you host
yourself I mean we got to sort of
believe that people actually go off and
do that I mean they could just stick it
in the cloud where no one will get at it
I don't know so we've got to think about
will people really really have a little
set-top box device up to their personal
data store and it doesn't your your
phone would in this instance I me could
be the Internet of Things or the
internet of junk as some people might
might call it your intuitive your house
is aggregating data your personal data
store shows your phone and there is a
API within which billion of the data is
queried not to just give up the data but
ask questions of it so you can't just go
give me a split me a list of GSM cells
was I in this gsm cell was I in this set
of GSM cell sweeps of in some of the
some sort of abstraction away so we're
from from done enough of the query
getting too creepy so that's one route
somewhere learned colleagues who started
in fact we inviting to do another act
days they are on their art is open
source net salvatori and Ariana and they
have a thing called the ubiquitous
Commons and they I mean this is kind of
brave and they've only just launched it
they're thinking about storing data in
something a bit like a bit like a
Bitcoin blockchain will sleep we'll see
how that pans out and I can integrate my
up with that and you can sort of think
about the so various cryptographic means
by which you allow or deny certain sorts
of dates to use my certain sorts of
people for certain sorts of applications
so that how we give that out is is the
next step when you're right there's sir
all sorts of ways in which though you
know people's data trails have been used
positively the big one is I mean the
mystic m comes from the natural language
processing course of that last week
looking at tweets in the in the outback
people that aren't very many of them and
the thing is you get massive fires in
the app back that burn for days because
no one's there to report them and if
someone's having a sees a whisper of
smoke on the horizon there a little bit
leery of you know calling the fire
brigade because what if they're wrong
and you can massively you know if you
look at loads and loads of two weeks on
the loads and loads of wisps of smoke on
the horizon and it worked so there's all
sorts of particularly looking at look at
look at our artists open source on that
well I'll tweak the link there's some
massively useful stuff they've done with
with local communities where something
like what we know we were in before the
social data Commons could actually do
good does that basically that little
rank answer your question yeah it's got
its uses and yeah yeah yeah see i was
thinking of specific some in the sorry
the current project you you having seen
what what what you got particularly in
terms of cell tower trails in clustering
and so on basically you softer that when
it gave it back to them and said that
we've got we've got elected this and
it's very interesting and here's your's
back and if you're and its source to
play with you i mean that the next that
mean it's only it's 20 it's 20
individuals so it's it's something about
a proof of concept we're onto the
questions and the discussions that is
that too quick ok ok ok there's another
european project called so big data
which is in some ways going to look at
expanding the sort of you're doing stuff
with social media and data scraping so
maybe some of it will live on maybe it
all become part of this ubiquitous
commons thing i mean
like it I'd like it to go forward it's a
proof of concept that shows what can be
done I mean we will what has yet to be
proved is how well can we integrate with
either personal data store or your
victims Commons and does it matter does
it work for the purposes of the project
it was about returning the data and
provoking discussion so it's it's
fulfill that purpose
yep
you mentioned
corporations
do you also develop some programmers and
hackers and individual
well one we haven't distributed the data
yet mental map I'm not so much worried
about large corporations as in the day
to its you know there's no sort of
political slant to this I mean that
they've got it already is the thing how
anonymous is I mean just because it's
got nobody's name on it is the data
anonymous yes certainly I mean yeah
we're very mindful that I've got a
leaner but we have got a list of school
kids basically you know of course but on
the other hand if you what do you really
have that somebody lives in the part of
Birmingham goes to school in Birmingham
and has visited some universities now
that we've got fear that we're
collaborating with the ODI the open data
to shoot for the name of the next part
of the project sort of how can we sort
of safely release this stuff and I've
got somebody you know the individual is
actually looking at it now seeing it
will have what's the winner what's the
worst-case scenario now if you it could
you scrape Twitter accounts of
Birmingham school kids and if they
mention three universities could you cut
you know it's yeah I mean worst case
scenarios do sort of keep me slightly
awake at night which is why we haven't
released the data yet it's it's
certainly an issue that so you know the
point of the project is to be not so
much though you know the the product but
to reason about the issues in other of
the product could we go can we do it
I think that's it is that it yeah two
more minutes for questions we've had to
in to our questions or one and a half
questions yeah yeah the other way and
and be amazing but to actually identify
where people are within a disaster
situation like technology PA or
something where you at that's a very
good point we're saying how nice we are
in obfuscating the data slightly and
having like sort of vague location data
and make when the crunch comes yeah I
mean though there are plenty of stores
where someone's been in the outback and
they've triangulated their phone and
they've been to the rescue Nick that's
interesting thought could we have cooked
I mean you maybe have it sort of context
sensitive look sort of don't tell people
where I live don't tell people where I
work if I'm breaking the pattern out how
we gotta do now we've got to detect the
pattern it's a machine learning them
that in fact that's the next stage I
don't I do want to get some spatial
temporal clustering going maybe thinking
about chucking SVM's at the time series
of clusters and you know I could do it
that way that's an interesting thought
I think we're done we're done thank you